if canceled culture is literally what it
sounds like it's you trying to take
somebody down and there's like a certain
type of either like accomplishment from
it and joy from it now mind you from
what we've seen especially with like the
me to movement you know there's a lot of
positive stuff that comes out of it
summertime like [ __ ] what's-his-name
Harvey Weinstein yeah [ __ ] creep I
mean the great thing that came out of
that is we all known like [ __ ] like this
goes down in Hollywood or in the
corporate world or whatever like you
know people use their position of power
to rape women or whatever and it's like
out now and it's like oh [ __ ] some
interesting comments that I remember
that I read was when we were talking
about the whole Bill Cosby thing and we
actually know somebody who were you guys
mentioned this story to me would there
was that story about the hair stylist
yeah yeah yeah makeup artist yeah that
was talking about how back in the day
she got harassed by Bill Cosby yeah he
straight-up came up and grabbed yeah he
called her boob yeah and then she was
like there's nothing you can [ __ ] do
about it yeah yeah and I think I don't
think a lot of people understand because
there was a couple of comments where
they mentioned well if you guys knew
this stuff you guys should have said
something so it's like well first of all
that was a hearsay story that we heard
through somebody else that's not fact
it's not fact that this is something
that I heard yeah so this is something
that we heard from somebody else so it's
already a watered down account that it
came through to other people uh-huh so
we don't we're not out here to ruin
somebody's career on something based on
hearsay yeah right and this is this is
generally what happens - yeah and
obviously for me to like Bill Cosby I
didn't want to believe that [ __ ] yeah yo
I adamantly defended that dude I mean I
even had hearsay about Harvey Weinstein
yeah out of my buddies he's a producer
in Vietnam and Harvey Weinstein his
company was they would license movies
Asian movies and in like and then like
release it here in the States right now
so he was he had a trip out in whether
it was Hong Kong or whatever but one of
his actors had an opportunity to work
with him because he was seeking her out
specifically so after the meeting with
with him they're like oh you want to
talk about like a role and then and
she's like sure so they went up to his
office or hotel room or whatever
was and then she came down and she's
like [ __ ] that guy I'm never gonna work
with them and then she never got the
role she never got an opportunity but
basically she told everybody like yeah
that guy just tried to [ __ ] creep on
me and he solicit he just said like you
want the role like [ __ ] yeah then I
already knew like this is like 2008
now this but when I heard this story
2008 or 2009
so it was like long [ __ ] time ago man
and and but it's funny that everybody in
the industry knew these things or who
has met him and how how open he was so
the problem is I think everyone [ __ ]
knew a lot of people knew because he was
like invincible there was there's a lot
of fear and um I have a friend to who
not too long ago experienced not to that
extent but she kind of experienced how
somebody can use their power over then
in entertainment because it's highly
career based yeah so for example um so
she she does like makeup and like a
wardrobe and all other stuff right so
how is kind of probably that's kind of
explained to me as this it goes okay so
your job so for me it's my job to dress
up this actor or whatever right and this
actor on set has all this power so mind
you if this actors not happy he feels
upset this whole film is based on this
person yeah and it doesn't go through
then well everybody's [ __ ] yeah so
it's it's it's beyond just her her job
that's everyone yeah careers on the line
and if if this actor is like throwing
off mm-hmm his moment like let's say
like he has a bad experience with I
don't know like the makeup artist yeah
and then he gets upset and he doesn't
want to do his role or he can't perform
well because now he's just so upset at
how rude that makeup artist was then
it's like you just [ __ ] up the whole
day for everybody yeah so for like in
her case it was it was kind of to the
point where he clearly was making a lot
of like sexual advances at her and you
know she was brushing him off whatever
she was handling it very well because
she's has experienced she has
experienced this before
yeah but how she was explained to me was
this she goes well let me put it to you
like this because I asked her like one
[ __ ] you
Tom - [ __ ] off she goes well David it's
not that easy cuz you have to think
about it like this I come in I say hey
don't do this blah blah blah blah I feel
really uncomfortable with you he gets
pissed off when it comes time for me to
dress him up which I guess like this has
happened to her before on a smaller
scale he goes I don't like I don't like
this [ __ ] you're not doing your job
right [ __ ] this like I'm not acting
thing I'm not doing this yeah it gets
pawn her she loses her job yeah then
she's gonna have even a harder time
booking another job because she's known
as the person that sucks on job and just
actors off so this is the type of power
that they have over people and I didn't
really think about that and these people
in position they [ __ ] know it they
[ __ ] know it too and I I never had
that perspective before because in my
mind I was just saying you know why
don't you just stand up for yourself and
tell the dude to [ __ ] off like it's not
that easy because these people are they
are the gatekeepers to another job or
another job opportunity that's why it's
nice that things are catching up to them
yeah because it's like all the people
that you [ __ ] did wrong all the
people that like couldn't stand up to
you yeah now it's catching up
[ __ ] it's okay and it's nice
it's nice to watch yeah cuz it's it's
almost like payback's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it really is though
men and I feel like a lot of people did
get away with a lot because they knew
nobody was going to say [ __ ] or it just
seems so far-fetched to a lot of yeah
and even for me it seemed far-fetched
like it was just a story but it didn't
like sit in my stomach is something real
right so somebody would tell me these
stories I'm like yeah I could see that
happening but like for us like it's
already watered down by the time it
comes to us yeah so we whistleblow who
the [ __ ] is gonna listen right I mean
like [ __ ] like the whole art Kelly [ __ ]
came out yeah I mean a lot of things
been happening and we know some people
that that's like old-school Hollywood
like they've been in since like the the
80s and 90s yeah I like and what I hear
is that today a lot of people are are
scared in many ways scared because like
the internet [ __ ] going digital and
things like that is is putting mad
pressure like there's there's no feature
film industry anymore yeah it's like
unless they're making a [ __ ] big
blockbuster thing or a Marvel movie like
yeah there's no middle
it's either independent companies doing
digital content or Netflix produce
things there's really no film industry
mm-hmm everything's moving the TV or
digital or whatever and so their careers
are all in the line not only that like a
lot of these actors these powerhouse
actors they're aging yeah although
there's an end there's no next
generation really that can stand up up
to par to these guys yeah and there's a
lot of shifts happening and on top of
that now with the me to movement now
with all this like people going against
the fraudulent Hollywood world there's
so many things that are like the old
guard is gonna change yeah it's gonna
it's an interesting time man and so
there's so much pressure they don't have
as much as they used to have like now
it's tainted like the secret's out a lot
of shit's gonna start surfacing yeah a
new media kind of opened up this gateway
because of you don't have to tell just
one person and that person who doesn't
believe you it doesn't have to be like
that right so let's say you told
somebody who was very significant about
this problem and they just don't believe
you well that's kind of just how it ends
right right back in a day yeah it's like
why I needed to tell this executive that
this happened but they don't believe me
there that's the end of the story now
you could get everybody on your side
yeah and that's what's cool about it
build your case and like the whole Cosby
thing if it was just one woman that told
somebody within that circle that this is
what they're like no that's not build
yeah [ __ ] are you talking about
10 pop out there like I've been quaalude
yeah you know like like 30 or 50 like
like it's crazy it's it's kind of hard
to deny at this point what sucks about
it though is the people who take
advantage of movements yeah and then it
kind of discredits it because during the
me to movement there were there were
there were women that were using it and
falsely accusing guys that never raped
them or whatever yeah Oh since people
were just so heightened it's that Bob
mentality they're like [ __ ] it I don't
care if he uses you know Oh innocent or
not let's get him [ __ ] Birnam and
that's when it went too far
yes it was like ah man like
now I could like I'm all for justice but
like we can't treat everyone like
Frankenstein you know like it's yeah
that's that's [ __ ] up yeah it got
really weird too especially with some of
some you know somebody put this out I
forgot it was on Twitter but I agree
with this a hundred percent and I kind
of wanted to do a video on this but
because she explained it so well there
was really no point yeah but she kind of
warned women of a lot of other women who
are in guise of somebody who is there is
support for females but they're really
not know right and so this kind of goes
hand in hand and she used Kim Kardashian
as an example all right so she is this
woman that says girls it's all about you
be badass it's all you know all this
other stuff but her actions speak
otherwise in terms of this like you suck
the dude's dick to get where you're at
yeah exactly right yeah so are you a
part of this me too movement and you're
really not but you know for somebody
like that they're trying to capitalize
on this movement to make them look good
yeah so they are not I guess
quote-unquote I hate this word but an
ally they are somebody who's using that
movement in benefit of them right up so
you sucked your dick all the way to the
top right you're telling women you
should love the way that you are but you
have asked implants tit implants
whatever that you have you have Botox
got your lips pumped yeah like what the
[ __ ] are you saying
like it's not all natural like how are
you how are you telling these women to
be comfortable with who you are and love
yourself when you're the person who has
the financial means to change any part
of your body whenever you want because
you actually don't love the way that you
look yeah and people don't have access
to that easy
so that crazy she would say [ __ ] like
that and expect not to expect to get
burned yeah
like who the [ __ ] are you you know that
blows my mind yeah so you know obviously
when when Kim Kardashian she was like
trying to hop onto that meet to boom in
she got a flame for it she guys as she
should yeah as well as other people
who's taken opportunities because what
happens is like let's say there was an
actress and she's like [ __ ] it I'll suck
a dick yeah cuz I mean I've said it
before yeah if I could get on the movie
I sucked the [ __ ] out of Jackie Chan's
dick let me I'll rush our [ __ ]
ten dude but he's in a wheelchair
spitting him around in the chair but I
mean all jokes aside right like there is
a woman that was cool with it
that was like [ __ ] it I'll do it it's
gonna get me to the top
but then what that what ends up
happening is like now dudes like
Weinstein are like oh [ __ ] it was that
easy well I could do it again maybe they
all down maybe a lot of women were cool
to do this [ __ ] yeah like I feel like
those women that try to hop on that me
to boom in its you're not a part of that
movement because you used whatever your
body your sexuality to get what you want
out of a situation it was a barter thing
right you traded something for something
got what you wanted and now you're on
the top yeah but how can you say that to
other other women and support them when
you basically prostituted yourself yeah
and for them it wasn't like that they
are told the other way around Eagles you
do this or you won't have this job yeah
exactly that's a completely different
situation that's like a drug dealer
that's like joining all the people like
yeah fair and square work hard and it's
like well yeah you did work hard for
drug dealing but at the same time man
like you're not paying taxes and you're
not doing what the rest of the people
are doing yeah
so you can't March with us it's not the
same it's not the same [ __ ] thing
yeah I think the problem that I think
when people want to talk about canceled
culture the the problem with it is now
it's like it's become a sport and a
hobby to to shut people down it's that
it's that it's that crab mentality right
like let's pull down the guy on the top
yeah I could use them to climb on top
you're like we got to cancel this person
you got a kid like [ __ ] are you and the
problem that I have with that is like
people are walking around like your [ __ ]
does not [ __ ] stink like your [ __ ]
your shits the same as my [ __ ] it's poop
baby we all poop it at all [ __ ]
stinks I love how people want to be so
like take like oh I'm gonna take the
moral higher ground but then like
they're such [ __ ] hypocrites yeah
like I'm getting so sick of that like I
understand we are all hypocrites to a
certain extent but people are trying to
burn some other human being as if they
haven't done worse like remember the guy
with the hole the Chinese dress thing
yes that [ __ ] Asian fast that [ __ ]
was like might my my cultures not a
costume right but then you
they found all all to all these old
tweets and he's using the n-word like
how many people but like these black
people this and that and derogatory way
- yeah it's like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are man I know
that's hilarious man it's hilarious that
biblical saying man let the first person
without sin cast the first stone
[ __ ] or in David's David's Dave
Chappelle's he he who is without sin
cast the first stone
and I shall smoke if a man and it's it's
if you are going to roast somebody for
doing something terrible in their past
that they've learned from that you
should be able to reflect that upon
yourself to it slightly okay take a look
at your past right did you learn from it
did you grow and if you're so
comfortable going ahead and judging
somebody else then you you damn well
should be comfortable for somebody else
checking out your tweets or whatever
you've done in the past and judge you
for it as well
that [ __ ] just recently happened to
Andrew Zimmern oh that's right yeah like
he basically said that Asian restaurants
in the Midwest tastes like horse [ __ ] or
whatever along the lines of that but he
said their horse [ __ ] right yeah which I
don't disagree with being an Asian
person who's ate a lot of Midwest
restaurants compared to Asia compared to
LA compared to areas that are
predominantly Asian if that is the
standard I would consider it horse [ __ ]
yeah wait was this what did he say this
that it was on his um it was on his new
show it's not it's not Bizarre Foods
it's another one yeah so he said it on
the show and that people were upset
about that yeah you know you know what I
I I mean like you